with free joe exotic you could have
taken that record to any major i'm sure
and then they could have put the bag
behind it their radio they could eat it
all that like it didn't make sense it
didn't make sense plus i didn't know the
business see see see you got to learn a
business bro yeah
so i'm like [ __ ] it let me do the indie
route let me take this little bag that
the indy got but while i i'm over here
and pay my bills pay attention take care
of my kids
it's going to be a roller coaster ride
let me learn a business let me float
it's going to keep me afloat
i'm just gonna do the work i'm gonna
learn the business though
you have to learn the [ __ ] business
man for sure
so
in that time
i'm learning the business while i'm with
this while while i'm while i'm with this
indy
i don't know what this distro right why
am i saying anything i want this dish
yeah
so
that's what i've been doing i've been
learning the business it's a lot of [ __ ]
that i didn't know
it's a lot of [ __ ] as we as artists
don't know
we don't have a clue
that's real and they wanted they wanted
to stay that way man that man them the
majors they're gonna lube their hand up
they're gonna [ __ ] you raw straight up
lube they dick up and [ __ ] you wrong man
and you don't know the business yeah and
why they [ __ ] you is
so you can learn a business and they can
profit at a large expense